video games just keep on coming and
there's a new halo the fifth halo came
Rob and Larry I and Eric Tay hello it's
bad halo wars I can ODST the ODST can
count scale or halo 5 yeah both you
gentlemen have played us hmm what have
you played so far because it's not the
entire game yet just the campaign okay
have you completed the campaign I
actually have not i'm a mission shy I've
been really busy this week but eric has
my completed it yes we're not allowed to
talk about story specifics no fine
brothers yeah okay multiplayer stuff is
starting soon enough we're gonna get to
play them yes this week ok tomorrow tune
in and we'll be doing some probably some
live stuff Oh excellent i'll be cool as
well as co-op so co-op we'll see some of
that as well tomorrow sweet so we might
get you back on the lobby as well to
talk about that then next week so i
guess the campaign you guys have played
it first of all rob how does it how does
it play does it feel like a halo game it
feels like a halo game more so i like
this game more so than 40 k for to me
felt like kind of desperate in some ways
like how it you know multi-player why is
it like tied in a lot of like seems like
forced call of duty elements like orange
drops a number being that the moment
kind of turned off by it yeah this arm
off the bat like just playing this game
feels so great just you're a massive
halo 5 i'll shoot videos you playing
like halo 1 and 2 and yeah really sort
of remembering the good old days does it
feel at all like that it does and that
it's it's much more simplistic like
there aren't these class oriented things
so far it's kind of just you know it's
got this new mobility thing it's kind of
the trend now right is the ad in the
dashed I didn't like you know uh
mantling and all these different moves
but it just flows so well like it was so
easy to pick up like the the power
abilities as like much as you you know
some people aren't into them you know
you do like a ground pound right when
you jump in the air and you charge up
you slam down enemies it's so gratifying
it's it's a blast and it just fits in
really nicely and what about like
environments and stuff tell you like one
of the things I love about halo is just
the diversity in the levels and like big
sort of outdoor stuff like fun
internal spaces and then crazy sci-fi
elements and different planets stuff
like what what does halo 5 does it have
that sort of diversity in it oh yeah
definitely a first and foremost it's
beautiful it looks amazing you know
different planets and different surfaces
and stuff like that I think just
speaking with you know Rob and even Mike
who play a lot of pelo uh they're saying
you know for the first time that there's
just so much more verticality there's so
much more space to kind of roam around
different paths you can take that aren't
as linear right mom so yeah it took you
touching on that that's so big like halo
4 for instance I enjoyed the campaign
but there wasn't much of a drive to go
back to it yeah this was almost
frustrating in the element of like I was
constantly trying to look around for
things to do because there are so many
different paths we have one of the
abilities you have is called a Spartan
charge where you can kind of plug you
know like plow through an enemy wherever
but there are these paths so they
basically hide from you like you can
basically find flanking maneuvers by
plowing through a rock formation and and
coming from behind and there is just
yeah here is listen you know I'm costly
huh well this is me just exploring like
an idiot you're all yours Intel you're
looking for right so that's why i right
so yeah there's you know it and touching
on that just a little bit more is is
basically you can see this being a
really great co-op experience because
there's so much to do and see in these
games and replay again like I'm looking
so here's an example of this you'll see
i plow through here to do it you idiot
do it okay here in the crock okay you go
and you can now flank an enemy it's sort
of fun Selleck what's the rest of the
gunplay like as well because the halo
sort of has this you know the formula is
like well known of like the AI the way I
guess the movements the the way the guns
work the sort of the AI in that game has
never been like the cleverest thing but
it's almost been by design so right how
does this feel does it feel like your
normal Halo game where like you're
playing groups of different types of
enemies that fight in different ways and
you're having to like figure out who the
strong one is and then totally you know
what's not like it's great I think it's
at its best more so yeah the AI is never
outstanding you're not you know you're
not blown away by them doing any
tactical maneuvers but you you take each
enemy and you handle them a lot
differently now for instance there are
these
nights right from the older game they're
more jacked up you have a new enemy
that's kind of the soldier who are
replacing these nights now the Knights
kind of leveled up and they're extremely
difficult right and you have to handle a
really different way to do is basically
shoot it glowing armpits great school
but that's where they're located uh
should we shoot this and you get one
chance to basically get a one-shot
headshot if you don't get it then you
can then you have to shoot the other arm
pit so there's like there are these
tactics you have for each enemy like
hunters now um I don't believe before
but more often maybe thorny of them and
they'll they'll bounce right back all
right so it's tough it was tough and I
didn't figure that one out right [ __ ]
and there's just tons of different
enemies and you handle you handle each
one differently and I think that's more
predominant than this one than any of
yours a good variety as well thread the
matrix alrighty i'll find the same three
things all the time not really no no
yeah you know you get hunters that this
is kind of always a apart we get two
hunters you know but it's a good variety
for each for each map III we talked a
little bit of the environmental stuff I
think you're not allowed to talk about
the thing I want to talk to you about
but you said you played one of the best
levels you think in the history yeah I
just to touch on a lightly without
spoiling anything you can't talk about
specifics it was just a really uh
breathtaking moment yeah when I was like
I posit and I had a text one we like
this is the best pillow ever played just
just and this was you know 10 seconds in
yes because it was it caught it caught
me off guard it was really fun yeah
basically just lightly touch alright
it's just a physics thing yeah they just
changed it was really good let the
viewers and you enjoy my aunt oh it was
like whoa that was one of coolest levels
i played like you remind me of like you
know like silent cartographer from like
yeah where you took an open world neo
handle this mission however you yeah so
is this one of those things like the
opposite of the library yeah scale
perfect beacon of cartographer actually
let's talk about the vehicle self a
little bit sure so what have I eccles
tell you're not a big fan of the
vehicles no I don't really yeah I just
yeah so I know it's a staple of halo
things Halo game sorry and maybe some
people are gonna kill me for this but I
think even Rob had some slight
frustrations with the two it's just like
as you progress through the game
as you know you are gonna get on a
warthog you're gonna you know you're
going to get into different vehicle she
or something advantages and what I and
just some of the some of the ground
transportation just frustrated me a
little bit and like hey here's a coin
right here is this mission where you
operate a mantis now what gets
frustrating i can i did this on heroic
and this took me really long i mean
legendary swords at and i will play an
on legendary for sure but man on this
this one legendary must be so tough
because what happens is you know you go
through this long trek and a mantis but
by the end of it you see I'm glowing red
because if I take one hit no and I'm
done so I did like two through
checkpoints it's keeping the hell yeah
so you're like it gets and this is kind
of I just get out of it's a staple like
okay Rovers but you can't get out of it
man missing man yeah but they don't give
enough they should give you like more
like a lot of these vehicle emissions
you ditch a vehicle and you get another
one yeah that happens a lot this one not
the case you get one mantis but by the
end of it you're like you're just
frustrated because you're so
conservative with that like how you're
playing like any small hit you're done
and so you're redoing checkpoints pretty
often and it got a little frustrating he
didn't like it he said he want to throw
his controller oh no sometimes this is
Eric Eric cat Mario tell you we're
talking about here yeah but like it was
just more of like because you know
you're in you're in the mantis and you
think okay I should be able to mow all
these guys down because I'm in a mantis
you are literally on the field and I
should be able to yeah your missiles my
my Gatling gun or whatever tanga and
just like just destroy them and then
instead there's so many of them that
it's like oh I guess I kind of got to
tactically cover my vehicle that's
supposed to be way stronger than these
just you know so a specific sort of like
you have specific things here and there
you guys are you know think doesn't work
perfectly but overall sounds like you're
pretty optimistic about it yeah I'm all
right Lisa campaign yeah kb is pretty
enjoyable there there's one thing i want
to touch on is like there's one thing
that like just kind of nag me in the
wrong way where you like other halo
games sometimes you know you like master
chief collection you you look for you
know like Easter eggs like like
terminals and this one its mission intel
each new mission has like i don't know
eight to twelve mission
yeah they're like us pick up a little
and you know it's a tape recording and
it's a little bit of the story the story
is sometimes hard to follow in general
um and you know you find these voice
recording pickups and you play it what's
frustrating is that it will play over
often more often not as happened it was
playing over the actual dialogue games
okay yeah so too much again another sort
of a you know nitty-gritty got a great
thing but which we'll get to in the
review but when the story is like you
know you did there they're throwing you
a lot of plot during the actual gameplay
and so when that starts happening I get
from yeah but Sam I'm like kind of miss
Mallon stuff of course you can go back
in the main menu and yo have you are you
but apart from that sort of like you
might join us oh I very much enjoyed it
the ya again the the gunplay it feels
like such a halo game and that's just
huge for me it's simple like it did you
don't need to somebody you know like I
feel like advanced warfare all these
games are tacking on all these you know
crazy glitchy movement stuff but this is
like yeah really tasteful kind of like
black ops 3 is doing this you like just
a tasteful you get one like you know I
mean you get one boost yeah either
you're you're jettisoning out of a fight
or you're using it to your advantage you
know you're doing a cheap move on
someone Soto it's it's a nice balance
it's good to hear and then the
multiplier stuff when you guys streaming
that's two minor / free tomorrow I won't
guarantee anything that we need to look
into that but we're definitely playing
tomorrow we're definitely playing co-op
tomorrow I know just to parking on that
point yeah I think campaign was fun is
pretty good but I think we can all agree
that if we were able to do it co-op I
think it's like a lot but I would have
enjoyed it i think so i guess i guess
you'll find f yeah so we'll get you back
on next week to talk about coop on is
multiplayer involved in as well as it
just go up whoa those are kind of
lifting at the seams okay they're kind
of looking at this is so much halo so
much video game in that oh yeah I'm a
knight in there just a week's time
October 27 is all right yep yeah please
round the corner it's around the corner
video games they're coming up
you